Yeah, back then I really thought it was like, it was the kind of job that only genius level
sort of people could work.
And then you met me.
Yeah, basically.
And then you knew, if this dumbass can do it, then I can do it too.
Yeah, that's...
Alrighty, sup y'all.
This time around, I'm sitting down with two of my best friends, So Sakaguchi and Kodai
Kabuno.
We're going to talk about the mentorship experience in Bug Bounty.
And we're going to talk about not only the ins and outs of how to do mentorship and, you
know, facts about how to do it.
But we're also going to talk about the messy thing that is learning Bug Bounty.
What kind of difficulties come up?
What kind of ways mentors can be counterproductive?
And what kind of lessons we've learned along the way in building, you know, sort of the
mentor-mentee relationship.
I hope you enjoy this episode.
I will also add in this segment, we forgot to do the giveaway.
And we were supposed to do it two weeks ago.
And then we didn't, and we got caught up with live hacking and stuff.
So congrats to at nchickens on Twitter for winning the Jay Haddix, the Bug Bounty Hunting
Methodology giveaway.
It's going to be an awesome course.
I'm super excited for you.
For those of you that didn't win, my condolences.
But you can still get a seat by hitting the description, hitting the link in the description
down below to go to Jay Haddix's website and sign up there.
It's probably the best $550 you'll ever spend.
So with that, I hope you enjoy the episode.
All right, you guys see this?
It is...
We have started the recording this time.
We just...
Yeah.
We just got like, you know, five minutes into the episode.
We went through our little pre-episode warm-up, pre-episode shake.
And then we realized we are not recording the audio at all, just the video.
So sorry about that.
A little bit of a false start.
But thanks for coming on.
Just for the audience, these two guys, these two lovely gentlemen right here are some of
my best friends from the time that I was living in Japan.
And yeah, man, just so many good memories with you guys in Japan.
And during, you know, being the bug bounty evangelist that I am, I, you know, had a conversation
with these guys about bug bounty, and both of them have expressed interest.
Xo has already gotten a job in the field, as he'll tell you in just a moment.
But both of them have sort of expressed a desire to work in cybersecurity in general, specifically
offensive cybersecurity and or bug bounty as a career path.
So we started to do some mentorship, some training, and that sort of things.
And that's kind of what I was thinking about, thinking we would talk about today is like,
what is a good blueprint?
What is a good pathway for a beginner to take coming into bug bounty?
And for people, the more advanced listeners that are here, which is most of our audience,
if you have someone that you're working with that you want to help grow in bug bounty,
how can you effectively do that?
So hopefully these two have brought some good constructive criticism for me today.
We'll see if they're able to put aside their Japanese tendencies about saying,
oh, everything's great.
Everything's great.
You know, and give me some actual constructive criticism.
But before we jump into that, let's, we'll go ahead and do an interview.
And since, or an intro.
And since on the fall start, we had So start his intro.
We're going to have Kodai start his intro this time just to keep you on your toes.
Hi.
I mean, first of all, thanks so much for having us on this podcast.
I'm really happy to talk to you on this.
And my name is Kodai.
I also go by the name of Kodai Chodai, which is my hack handle.
And I'm currently not really working.
Yeah.
But I'm in search of new opportunities.
I'm in the process of actually applying for a couple of Japanese cybersecurity companies.
And you've already graduated, right?
Yeah.
I guess it's about it.
So anybody who's in the Japan cybersecurity space, hit Kodai up if you've got any opportunities.
And well, I guess maybe we'll circle around to that again after you listen to Kodai talk
in this podcast about his experiences and what kind of stuff we've worked on together in the
Bugbani realm.
All right.
So you're up next.
So my name is So.
And my Hakawana account is Mokuso.
And I started Bugbani and cybersecurity stuff from three years ago, thanks to Justin.
Also now I'm working as a full-time security engineer at the GMO, a Japanese company.
Would you say that it's a security engineer position?
It's pretty much entirely offensive security, right?
Yeah.
It's like a web application tester.
Web application tester.
Yeah.
Also doing a bit of like Bugbani as a hobby.
Nice.
Like trying to find some CVs and stuff.
That's also another hobby.
Very cool, man.
Very cool.
So I guess let's, since So's already got the mic, when did you start getting interested in Bugbani's?
And give us a little background, education background, and then how you switched sort of
skirt, change, change, change, change paths into Bugbani.
I think that was, that was exactly three years ago.
Oh, really?
Three years ago, October.
Yeah.
Pretty much.
Pretty much this day, right?
Yeah.
This season.
Wow.
I was a senior of university in Japan.
And my major was French regional studies.
So I was studying French and also do some like French.
What university was that in Japan?
The Tokyo University.
Tokyo University.
The top university in Japan.
So let's just put that out.
The Harvard of Japan of sorts.
Let's put that out there.
It is.
Continue.
Yep.
So I wanted to be like, I didn't have like a specific dreams, but that time I kind of
want to be a diplomat because I thought it's cool.
Also, I was studying English and French.
So I thought it would be a great fit for me.
Right.
So that was like three years ago.
And then I met Justin at a like a Bible study of my church in Yokohama and started to hang
out with him.
And so one day we went on a trip together and there like he kind of introduced me about
like what he does.
Also like his job and bag money and stuff.
And I got interested.
And that's how I got started.
Yeah, man.
So I just, I think that experience is a little bit kind of crazy to me.
Looking back on it, because I remember the time the conversation So and I had when he,
you know, and at this point you had no IT experience at all.
Yeah, zero.
Not even really using the computer for anything besides just schoolwork.
Right.
Yeah.
And so, you know, for him to be like, yeah, you know what?
Actually, I'm really interested in that.
I would like to learn how to do that.
My first reaction is like, of course, you know, this guy is smart because he's at this
university and because I've had conversations with him.
But the chances of you actually doing that were very slim, in my opinion, in my experience.
Right.
And so when you said that, I was like, okay, I'm going to give you some reading material.
Okay.
Yeah.
And I gave you some reading material and something amazing happened, which was that the next time
I talked to you, you had read it all.
Right?
Yeah.
Which doesn't sound that crazy, but it really is.
You had read it all.
And you not only had you done that, but I remember you came back to me and you said, hey, so at
this one point in this one piece of material, it references application JSON.
And I didn't know what that was.
Yeah.
It is.
And so I was looking that up.
And then, like, you know, you had some question about JSON structure.
So it showed that you went another layer deeper in the learning material as well, which
really made an impact on me and really impressed me with that.
So, you know, that's why we kind of moved forward with the Bug Bounty, I think, piece
for you, or at least with the more active hands-on mentorship, because that was a really
impressive moment for me.
And so diving into that first, I don't know how clear of a memory you have of this, but
diving into that first material, how was that?
I mean, do you remember being particularly lost or how did you take that first step?
Because the first step is a big one.
So first of all, I think one thing I really remember is, like, because Justin told me
that he's doing Bug Bounty and seems like, you know, he's good at it.
So I checked Haka on website and I saw him ranking at, like, 11th or, like, 12th at, like,
annual ranking.
Yeah.
And that was, like, probably one of the most, like, the biggest things to me.
And I was like, if, you know, if you're good at something that's good, if you're good at,
like, if you rank at, like, 11th in the world, that's impressive.
Like, not just impressive, that's, like, pretty good.
Right.
Super good.
And if your friend ranks at 11th in the world at something, then you got to learn that, right?
You got to at least know, like, the basics, right?
That's a very weird way of thinking about it.
Like, yeah.
Because that's such a precious opportunity.
There are, like, only 11 people at the same level.
So that's how I got interested.
And for the material that you gave me, that's, like, really hard.
Because, like you said, I didn't know what JSON is.
I didn't know what PHP is.
Like, I really have no idea what, like, any concept of anything in the books were.
So that was really hard.
But also I was like, this looks pretty, like, interesting because I know nothing about this.
And so, you know, every time you came across something new, it's just starting sort of a
recursive process of, like, now I go read about that, right?
And then, you know, you dive deeper on that.
And I think the fact that you were able to do that is really, really impressive.
And it's probably one of the key indicators of your success to this point.
But we'll come back to that.
Could I?
So I guess the question that I wanted to ask you is a little bit different than the question
that I wanted to ask So for this one.
So So and I had already started sort of doing some hacking stuff when you, I guess, got more
interested in it.
But I also feel like there was some sort of pre-interest or at least pre-time when you
expressed interest to me that you wanted to be, you know, get into hacking.
What kind of experiences did you have prior?
What kind of stuff did you look up?
What kind of image of hacking did you have prior to saying, hey, Justin, I'd like to learn
more about Bug Bounty?
Wow, that's a really good question.
I think, yeah, I think it goes all the way back to when I was 13 or 14.
That's when I was first introduced to the world of hacking technically.
Yeah.
I basically watched this documentary-ish thing by a Japanese TV program.
It was about this American hacker guy named Max Butler, I think.
Also known as Iceman.
And he was basically working for FBI, surreptitiously doing some black hat hacking.
Oh, really?
Yeah, stealing so many credit card numbers and stuff.
Yeah.
So that, in a way, yeah, to be perfectly honest, really fascinated me.
It wasn't like, hey, I want to steal credit card numbers and get rich as well.
No, but I was just, you know, I think it was the capability he had, you know, over the
world of the internet.
Yeah.
Yeah, because it was physically basically just him and his laptop.
Right.
So I was like, holy shit.
Yeah.
Can really one person do that?
It definitely appeals to, you know, the more individualistic type, you know, because like
you said, it is you and your laptop against all the defenses or the world, you know, at
that point.
Yeah.
That was super nuts.
But at that time, I never really looked at it as a realistic career path that I might
be able to take because, yeah, back then I really thought it was like, it was the kind
of job that only genius level sort of people could work.
And then you met me.
Yeah, basically.
Yeah.
And then you knew if this dumb ass can do it, then, you know, I can do it too.
That's.
No, no, no, no, no.
Just kidding.
But you really made me, you know, you really sort of proved that you can, you know, work
that as a job.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
As an ethical hacker.
Right.
And if you reach a certain level, I mean, it could be very, very high, but once you reach
it, then you might be able to live nomadically, which was, you know, something I was always
sort of dreaming of doing.
Yeah.
I remember talking, I was talking about this.
That was, that was one of the end goals for you in general was to be able to, I guess,
work remotely and even further need, further.
Man, my, my Japanese is getting in the way.
Cause whenever I have a conversation with these guys, I, I, we switch out of in and out of
Japanese and, and, and English.
So it gets in the way, but we'll try to keep it English for this.
So furthermore, you know, if you're able to do that on your own schedule, right.
On your own timeline, that's a big plus for you.
Mm-hmm .
And I think, yeah, I remember, I remember you mentioning that in the beginning.
So that's, that's one of the main, I guess, motivators for you too, right?
Yeah.
That's, that's, that's definitely, that's definitely a big, you know, that was one of
the, that's the thing that brought me to Japan in the first place was the fact that I could
work remotely and working on my own, own time schedule.
Mm-hmm .
That was really, that was really big.
Could I, so then, you know, we started talking a little bit, you started seeing me and so start
working on stuff.
Yeah.
And it starts to sort of materialize in your brain, hey, this is a, this is a route that
you, you could go.
Um, I guess, I think I know So's answer to this already because So, just straight from the
beginning, So was like, okay, wait, I've never even heard of this.
Okay.
Teach me, you know?
So there wasn't any sort of pre-research before you and me sort of establishing a, a mentee
mentor relationship, you know?
But for you, Kodai, was there any research you did into hacking or like that before you
got started?
Uh, kind of.
Yeah.
I also did the, you know, uh, one of the things that So did, just, you know, looking up your
name.
Yeah.
And because I, you know, before I met you, I basically heard that, you know, from one of
our mutual friends that you're basically one of the best hackers out there.
And I was like, okay, okay, sure.
Yeah, sure.
Right.
And then I, you know, looked it up and wow.
But I was, it was still, it seemed really unrealistic to me, you know, cause I didn't,
I wasn't really familiar with cybersecurity or anything or it in general.
Right.
But I think, yeah, in that sense, So really showed me that without having any, you know,
uh, yeah.
He was a French major.
Yeah.
Just it or.
You know, programming experiences, you could actually start it.
Mm-hmm.
So yeah, I think after watching him, uh, doing some hacking, you know, doing some mentorship
with you, I, yeah, finally made a decision to, you know, do the same thing.
Look at my, look at my, my guys, my guys, I love it.
And, and, you know, So and I have, have had, you know, so many good hacking experiences together
already as well.
And, and, and Kodai, we've had a handful as well.
Um, and so it's so great to be able to do this job with you guys, you know, even, even
as the, uh, you know, as the gap begins to close a little bit in knowledge and, and so
starts teaching me stuff about stuff, things that I don't know.
And, and, uh, and, you know, as you continue to grow there as well, Kodai, I think it'll
be even more fun.
Um, so it's happened.
So it's, you know, here's the other thing, man.
And I think as, as a mentor, you, when you're having to re-explain stuff as well, you start
to question, right?
Like for example, the time I tried to, you know, do a C-surf and I deleted your, I deleted
his like go-to music account via C-surf because it had a premium account.
Uh, and I learned some stuff about, uh, same site strict cookies that day.
Right.
Um, so as we continue to grow together, not, not just, you know, you guys growing, but I
grow as well.
So that's really cool.
Um, the next question that I had, and I guess I should probably pick one of you to answer
this.
Yeah.
Let's, let's hear from so, um, so can you think of any time where you sort of had like
a aha moment that where you, you really started to understand some piece of hacking or has it
just been really, really gradual?
I'd say it's been always really, really gradual and always like looking backward.
I, I'm like, Oh, I've made a bit of progress.
Right.
You know, over the last few months or over the last year, something like that.
Yeah.
So, so probably not any, any like, you know, all of a sudden the lights come on and you
can see moment on any of that stuff.
Yeah.
I, I suspected that that would be the case.
Um, for you.
So, I mean, I guess we started off.
Um, I guess working in the same way that I, we started working with, with Kodai, which
is access control, uh, vulnerabilities and XSS and, and, uh, IDORS and stuff like that.
Um, do you think that's the same route you would take now?
Uh, do you think that you would change any of that at all?
Um, or, or do you think that that is the correct path to get you to where, to where you're at?
You can think about that for a second if you need to.
Yeah.
I guess if someone starts from where I was, which is like absolutely zero basics, like
zero knowledge on cybersecurity or like even like computer science as a whole, I think that
was the correct route.
Um, cause like now it's like one of the, you know, one of the easy ones, right?
Mm.
But like three years ago, I could barely understand like what access control bags are and how I
can exploit that.
Like the same for IDOR.
Mm.
I mean, of course, if you go further with like a Bishop Fox, Jason, certain stuff,
there are more complex IDOR things, but like easy parts of IDOR and access controls is,
I think comparatively easier to understand for like beginners like me three years ago.
So I think it was a good route.
Yeah.
I kind of wish we had recorded this podcast a little bit closer to our, it's been about what?
It's almost, it's been about two years, maybe a year, if we count some of the time you were in America.
Um, since we really did some hardcore hands-on mentorship, right?
So I'm sure, I'm sure some of that has faded a little bit now.
Um, you know, the, the, the, the techniques and the way that I sort of taught some bug bounty stuff,
but the way, the way, if I recall correctly that we approached this was, you know, we, we first explained,
um, what happens when you put a URL in a browser, right?
And, and hopefully, you know, at that time, you know, we, we, I, we drilled that pretty often.
We did that a lot.
Right.
Um, and, and I think that's, you know, once you have that sort of foundation in place,
then, then you can start moving on to those, those sort of vulnerabilities.
Do you think you had, because we, we probably went over that part of it 10, 15 times, right?
What happens from, from our user puts the URL in the browser, you know, it converts the domain name
into, it parses the URL, pulls out the domain name, converts the name, domain name into an IP via DNS.
And then it instances the TCP connection.
We, you know, we went through all of that probably 10, 15 times.
Do you think that having that basis allowed you to grip something like IDOR and access control
bugs a little bit, a little bit easier?
Or do you think it would have just been better to just be like, Hey, here's an HTTP request.
This HTTP request, you know, controls how the computer talks to the server, rotate the ID.
See, see the vulnerability.
I mean, what do you think?
Do you think that's too deep?
He just said, he just said in Japanese, oh, that's a tricky one.
Uh, I'm going to think about that for a second.
So.
Yeah, I guess for one, I wouldn't say I've mastered like TCP stuff.
Right.
And like, yeah, still, I, I see we learn all these things.
And sometimes when I have to learn some like HTTP two things,
like, you know, I just always realized that I don't understand absolutely like anything.
Right.
But everyone has that moment.
I think basic was necessary.
And also like, at the end of the day, you have to learn that.
Right.
So I think learning just basics.
Ah.
I don't know if it's related.
Okay.
All right.
No, no, no.
I like this take.
This is, I don't know if you guys know this English vocabulary word, but hot take.
Have you, you guys, Kodai knows that.
So doesn't know it.
So, hot take is like a, an opinion that is different than, you know, one might expect
or what popular culture believes.
Right.
So this is, this is a hot, it might be a little bit of a hot take here.
So, so tell me about why you're changing your mind a little bit on this.
So one, so, so the, one of the reasons I was learning cyber security and hacking from
you three years ago was like I said, because you're like one of the top hackers in the world.
So I like, didn't really matter how fast I can grow, like how much money I can get.
It was just like a pure hobby.
And I just wanted to understand at least basics of what you do.
So that's why, you know, try, trying to understand DNS stuff, DCP stuff, all these things matter to me.
Hmm.
So for me personally, it was necessary and I really enjoyed that.
But at the same time, I don't, I'm not super sure if that helped me understand access control thing,
either things like business logic things better at that time.
Hmm.
That I'm not sure about.
So, so you guys both listened to the podcast, you know that we like to debate here a little bit.
We like to do some, we like to do some critical thinking, right?
You like to debate.
I like to debate.
So I'm going to, I'm going to, you know, I'm going to play some devil's advocate.
I'm going to take, you know, the other side for a little bit, but first I want to hear Kodai's opinion.
So Kodai, same sort of question.
Is it important to know that piece that I talked about when you put the URL in the browser,
what happens before you start learning things like IDOR and access control vulnerabilities?
Yeah, that definitely was necessary for me.
Yeah.
And yeah, in that sense, that was a really good start.
Um, because I feel like that was the really, at least to me, the bare minimum that I really needed
to actually go, uh, look for some bugs.
Mm-hmm .
I mean, in this case, only IDORs, but yeah.
Yeah.
So, and obviously I didn't really, you know, at that time when I, when you just, you know,
explain how, yeah, just starting from, you know,
just messing with the, with the URL, um, URL bar and just how briefly like all the HTTP messages,
you know, work, um, I didn't have a comprehensive understand, understanding of, you know, how IDORs
could actually happen and stuff.
Right.
It's sort of foundational knowledge.
Mm.
But I could still, you know, as a matter of fact, go find some bugs.
I mean, obviously with your help, but yeah.
So yeah.
That worked pretty well for me.
Yeah.
And I think, I think that makes sense too, but so, so, so all right, so let's, let's,
let's give it back to so here and let's, let's have a little, little chat about this.
Okay.
So on one hand, I do agree.
I do agree that, um, you know, it would be possible to, to search otherwise, but I think for me,
and it sounds like maybe the case is for Kodai as well, it's kind of hard for us to visualize
what's happening until we understand what's happening at a little bit of a lower level.
Right.
Because like, if I say to you, I mean, I guess you could understand at the level, like we put a,
we put these HTTP requests in a box, you know, in this box inside a burp suite, right.
And we, we changed the number and we pressed send, uh, and then that just communicates to
the server.
I guess we could do it at that level, but do you think it would be hard for you to grip
conceptually what's happening without that explanation?
Or do you think really gripping what's happening conceptually, uh, you know, comes even later
after the URL explanation?
What do you, what do you think about that?
Like, do you have to understand what's happening on the backend for you to really see the full picture?
So I guess, um, I kind of agree with Kodai.
Mm.
Like, you know, where he put it.
Right.
I would say, you know, I kind of start to get persuaded.
But what I, my point was like,
Mm.
Yeah.
At that level is related, you know, but it's not directly related.
So, well, it's a little bit early on too, you know, in your, in your, in your experience to
really have to take in a bunch of technical information, like RFCs, you know, reading HTTP,
RFC, talking about, you know, TCP level connections, which we'll never use ever again.
Mm.
Right.
So really, it's mostly the HTTP layer, right?
That we need to be understanding.
Mm.
Do you agree?
I mean, like at the end of the day, like, I really kind of, this argument really makes
me, I remember the argument of, you know, the hacker, the hackers need to like program.
Mm.
Yeah.
And like, I think answers from most hackers are like, not absolutely necessary, but absolutely helpful.
So like, this is similar.
Yeah.
This is, I feel like this is similar.
Like, it should be a thing, super helpful to understand IDOR, but is it like absolutely
necessary?
Then I don't think it, it is.
Yeah.
That makes sense.
I think, I think, I think that's a really good parallel, you know, drawing, drawing those
parallels in between, because you can, you can kind of see, like you said, you really could
find it simple enough where you really could, if you understood the concept of IDOR, this concept
of an ID and this concept of trusting the ID from the client side, right?
!
Yeah.
Let's talk about the times when us three are sitting in a room, hands on the keyboard.
Okay.
Yeah.
Boy, yeah.
Boy, Justin's a little quirky sometimes.
Right.
So, uh, I have a little bit of an eccentric style or a little, a bit of an odd style of teaching
bug bounty.
Um, what, what are some things that worked for you and some things that didn't work for
you with the teaching, teaching style?
I, I, and I, once again, I know this is a couple of years back, but, um, you know, I, I often,
for example, to give you an example, how'd you teach things back to me?
Mm-hmm.
What, what do you think about that and other teaching styles?
So first, since you got the mic or if you need to think we can give it to Kodai too,
I, we'll, we'll, we'll, we'll, so it's taken a little, I, I caught so after a work day here.
It's just, it's, it's, it's taking a second.
All right.
Uh, Kodai, what do you, what do you think about that?
Um, yeah.
So yeah, your style of mentorship, you know, having us, uh, okay.
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait, before you get, I can see before I, we get into this, this is not supposed
to be a Justin, you're amazing bloody blow sort of session.
Okay.
So please try to keep that to a minute, a minimal.
Got it.
This is, this is supposed to be, talk to me about the efficacy of the technique.
Okay.
So this is going to be my genuine opinion.
Mm-hmm
And, uh, yeah, the thing that you just touched on, you know, um, you having us, uh, explain
what you just explained to us that really, yeah, that's actually one of the,
the greatest things you did for us, I guess.
Mm-hmm
Yeah.
It was, could be very challenging, but definitely to understand how, um, almost anything, I guess
you need to, you gotta be able to, you know, have the capability to reproduce what you just
did, you know, explain what you just learned.
So yeah, that's definitely one thing I really liked about your, uh, style.
Do you think it was, it was too stressful?
I feel like I'd be lying if I said, not at all, but, but, uh, you know, that's the, I really
needed that stress, you know, for my brain.
For my brain and that definitely, yeah, pushed me to, um, you know, spot what I didn't really
understand precisely.
Yeah.
Just troubleshooting issues properly.
Mm-hmm
Yeah.
So
Have you, have you thought about, so this, this is a common technique.
It's, it's probably interesting because, you know, I'm making you guys do this, but really
what I'm doing, the technique that I'm sort of mimicking, it goes way back further, um,
and back into, you know, history, uh, sort of rooted in the Socratic method, um, with Socrates,
a philosopher, uh, but, uh, more commonly it's used in IT, uh, a little bit, a little bit
different, but related topic called the rubber ducky method.
Have you guys heard of that?
No.
Rubber duck?
Yeah.
Okay, Sohas, um, so essentially the way that you can reproduce this for yourselves as well
is may force yourself to explain stuff to inanimate objects.
So a lot of programmers, they'll have a rubber duck and, you know, yellow rubber duck sitting
on their, on their, on their desk.
Right.
And they'll, uh, they'll explain things to that duck to try to help them figure out where
the flaws in their logic are.
Right.
And I have that with a little stuffed animal Pokemon Dratini on my desk.
I don't know.
Cause then Pokemon names are different in Japanese.
I don't know if you know Dratini, but he's kind of like a, like a lizard snakey boy.
Uh, it evolves into big dragon.
Um, uh, but yeah, so that's, that's a, that's technique.
Have you guys used that at all in, in your life before?
Or is this something that I should have equipped you with years ago that might've helped?
That's, I've definitely used that.
Yeah.
Um, even when I try to just practice my, you know, pronunciation in English and stuff.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
It's basically about talking to some, something imaginary.
Right.
Yeah.
Um, yeah.
I do that too.
The wall, the air.
Um, yeah.
And I definitely, you know, do the same thing, uh, in cybersecurity.
Yeah.
What, what about you?
So do you have, uh, do you got any stuffed animals you talk to?
I mean, I do that always with my friends.
Oh really?
You know, I mean like accidentally.
Right.
Like when I was a high school student, I always did it.
Now you all know what kind of guy.
So it's like, Hey man, you know, let me tell you about this new Jason article I read, you
know, like, and like, yeah, when I was a high schooler, I did it to my sister.
Oh, right.
They're like complex math problems I cannot solve.
Right.
And I, you know, bring it to my sister cause my sister is pretty smart.
And then like, like, and then like halfway through, I'm like, Oh, I know, sorry.
I know, I know how to do it.
Right.
And then these days I do with my hacker friends, you know, like real stuff, for example, I can
send a message on discord.
I'm like, what did it, what, what this is?
I don't understand.
Right.
And halfway through, I'm like, sorry, I do understand.
Yeah.
It's great when you've got friends on other time zones for that too, because they won't, they
won't respond right away.
And then you still just wake up to a barrage of messages.
Like, Oh dude, this is the weirdest thing.
I can't figure this out.
What's going on?
Here's what's happening.
I got it actually, you know, so that's good.
Um, so what do you think?
I mean, do any other, um, so essentially the goal of this, this sort of portion of the
podcast is to try to equip the listeners with techniques that they can use to help other
people, their mentees grow or mentees themselves, how they can grow.
So do you have any other things that come to mind from your experience?
Um, you know, working as a mentee or collaborating on y'all spoke down any growth together that,
uh, that come to mind any techniques or thoughts?
So for me, I think like, like all like these, like teaching styles or even like tips that
you gave me really helped me for sure.
But at the end of the day, I feel like it's about me, right?
If I want to improve myself, I have to work hard.
So I think, um, what I learned from you the most would be like, you know, motivation, curiosity,
you know, just, you know, stick to it.
And then how did I convey that to you?
Was it an example or was it something that I said with words?
Cause when we, when we have together, sometimes you become unresponsive for like four hours.
Like seriously, um, that was like, I think one of the most important things to me.
Wow.
Like, of course, like, no, I mean, don't get me wrong.
I, I think I learned a lot of tips, like really great things from you.
But for example, like those things, if you push hard, you can kind of hard, like find them on Google sometimes.
Right.
For sure.
But like, I learned, I learned them from Google.
Yeah.
Right.
But in terms of like curiosity or like this attitude of like stick to your computer for 12 hours.
So you find some vulnerabilities.
That's like, I think the biggest thing I learned from you.
That, yeah, I think it's different seeing somebody do it in person too.
Yeah.
You know, that's one of the things that I've done.
I've learned from the live hacking events is like, you know, at least for me, I typically require a, um, a pretty uninterrupted environment to work in, you know, but you know, when at the live hacking event, it can be a little bit hard for me to focus or, or work with others.
Right.
Like I normally try to get my headphones on and try to get in the zone.
I wasn't really sure how to like actually collaborate with other hackers in an effective way.
But being at the live hacking events and seeing people collaborating together, seeing what worked with them, it makes you realize it's possible.
Right.
Um, so it's not always, it's not always the technical tips, right?
It's not a, I guess is what you're saying, you know, it's, it's about the work ethic and the, and the drive as well.
And I think you had that as well.
And you brought up a great point about sort of knowing yourself, um, and how you learn and how you work.
Right.
And at the end of the day, pushing yourself to find the vulnerability just through grinding essentially.
And it makes me think of one, um, of a quote that I remember from you working together, which was, you're looking at your screen and you're getting kind of frustrating.
You're like, ah, all right, I need some carbohydrates.
That's what you said to me.
And I was like, dude, that is not how I think at all.
You know, like, like, like I, I, um, you know, I'd be like, oh man, what, what, like, why can't I focus right now?
Like, this is so annoying.
You know, I get frustrated at that, but you know, from your own, I guess, from studying experiences that you're like, ah, you know, this feeling, I know this feeling.
I've, I've felt this feeling before.
This is me needing to have carbohydrates.
Right.
Um, so how do you, I mean, is that something that just kind of came natural to you?
Or is that something you had to start doing cognizantly is starting to learn, you know, yourself and how, what makes you study best and what makes you focus best?
Super hard question.
Uh, we don't, we don't, we don't do easy questions here on critical thinking, my man.
So for one carbohydrate thing, sweet things.
That's like pretty much like Japanese saying, you know, I'm I'm on you do a, you know, I need some sweet things.
Oh, really?
To make my brain work.
So that's the one.
Interesting.
Yeah.
I wonder if it's a, I wonder if it's a cultural piece, you know, like, like, I guess, and I guess this is, I mean, this is just scientifically true, right?
You know, that carbohydrates will help you focus in the short term, you know, right?
Or sugar, sugary things will be focused in the short term, but long term, it's not, not the best.
So if you're at the end of your like, you know, studying cycle or whatever, and you're really having trouble crossing the finish line or finishing, then you could hit some carbohydrates.
That's a, that's an interesting, that's an interesting little tidbit there.
Maybe I thought you were genius, but maybe it's just your Japanese.
Maybe so.
Yeah, maybe so.
Solid, man.
Yeah.
So I think a lot of, a lot of, I guess, growing and hacking has to do with that sort of learning yourself.
And, and that sort of thing.
Anything else come to mind between the two of you about, about, I guess, either learning environment pluses or learning technique?
Okay, so let me ask you about this.
Okay.
So when you work with a mentor, one of the reasons I won't mentor people is because it takes a lot of time, right?
And I don't have time to mentor everyone.
And this specific industry is not very conducive to mentorship.
Because at the end of the day, if I teach you about IDOR, you didn't learn the skills necessary to learn IDOR by yourself.
Hopefully that wasn't my phone just, but you know, you don't learn the skills that you need to, to learn IDOR yourself.
You learned it from me.
So how has it been transitioning from, uh, mentorship in bug bounty to self-education?
And let's start with Kodai on that one.
If you're, if, if that's not too much on the spot, cause I know it's a complicated question and it really, really is.
Yeah.
Um, Hmm.
I think in that respect, I'm still in the process of, you know, really making that transition in a way.
Yeah.
Developing that skill.
Really just, you know, having more self-discipline to just, you know, keep, um, to really stick to my computer, you know, for many hours.
Um, can you share any tricks that you have?
Cause that's journey, right?
That whole, that whole experience of developing that, that skill is a journey.
And I forget that journey.
I don't really remember what it was like to not know how to take technical concepts and break it down.
Mm-hmm.
And, you know, assimilate it and bring it into my brain, you know?
Um, and especially coming from a non-technical background, like English for you and French for so.
Mm-hmm.
Um, I'm wondering if there's any tips you can share for the people that are in a similar spot in trying to develop that skill in the first place.
And even things that haven't worked, you know?
Mm-hmm.
Like maybe I, I tried taking a break every 10 minutes, you know, and then just discovered that that didn't work, you know?
And anything that comes to mind on that, on that front.
That's a really good question.
Mm-hmm.
I think it's a really simple thing and everyone says this, but I guess like you just have to find what you love to do, right?
Like, like for the first few months, uh, when I just started to do backbounty and the first few months where I started to get some bounties, I was like, I was telling to all my friends, like, you guys all gotta do this.
Mm-hmm.
Because you can make money.
Right.
But like from like a year ago or two, I started to realize that I can do this because I love to do this.
It's not because there's money hanging there.
Mm-hmm.
Because of that.
I just do this because I love to learn new things.
Mm-hmm.
And because I think hacking is really cool and something that helps others.
So that's like, so I don't like try to force myself to study further or like push harder, you know?
So, okay, that's true.
Mm-hmm.
That's definitely true.
So focus on doing the things you love, the specific vulnerability type that you love, you know, maybe you should just dive deep into that because you're fueled.
And it's gonna be so much easier.
The friction's gonna be less.
But we all get to the point, so, where we've read the JavaScript files 10 times and we need to hack this target.
And we can't hack it.
Mm-hmm.
And you're exhausted and you hate it.
You know?
And I, but okay, okay.
But he does actually have a little bit of a weird saying though, that Mariah, my wife, always says about so.
He's like, when somebody asks her what kind of person so is, Mariah says, he's the sort of person that says this, don't you just love that feeling when your brain is so tired that you can't do anymore?
End quote.
And so, I mean, do you have those moments or is it just.
Of course, of course I have.
But.
And do you push through or do you give up?
I give up.
Okay.
Because I think that's one thing that's different from you.
Mm-hmm.
Because I'm not full-time BlackBounty hunter.
Right.
At the end of the day, I have a full-time job that gives me.
Yeah.
Stable income.
Monthly salary.
So, I always stick to what I kind of want to do.
Mm-hmm.
So these days I'm not necessarily doing BlackBucks, BlackBounty whole time.
Trying to find CVs, trying to, you know, understand other people's fine.
Right, right, right.
Stuff like that.
And whenever I feel like, I don't feel like, you know, going farther on this path, I just
give up.
That's really insightful.
And I think that can get you really far.
I mean, clearly, that can get you really far.
And I think a lot of the bug bounty stuff that we talk about is a very grind heavy mentality.
And I think if you are to do bug bounty full-time, you will run into those sort of grind situations.
But you also have to know when to set it aside and say, hey, I'm actually not going to grind
anymore on this.
I've got, you know, enough bugs in my pipeline that's going to pay my bills.
I don't need to sit here and shred my brain, you know, trying to figure out some of this
stuff that isn't necessarily relevant to or is too much mental expenditure, too much mental
cost, right, for what it's worth.
And maybe move on to a different target or maybe pivot around.
That being said, I made this mistake earlier on in my career where I would do manual testing,
but I would do it wide.
And I would move very quickly over the attack surface.
And this is something that Douglas Day and I, Archangel, sort of debated on the last podcast
was like, how quickly do you move on from a target?
How quickly do you move on from a section of the application?
And I noted that when I started being more stubborn about an attack vector or about a bug,
I started finding better bugs, you know?
For the first like two years, maybe not quite two years, about two years of my bug bounty journey,
I never found a five digit vulnerability.
So vulnerability above $10,000.
And then when I started being a little bit more stubborn and a little bit more, you know, mentally resilient,
I started finding more bugs of higher impact, but less bugs overall, right?
Which is definitely a mentality shift.
So yeah, I'm sorry, bringing it back around, Kodai.
Did you have any thoughts on...
What was my question now?
I guess, do you have any thoughts on what things have worked for you and haven't worked for you developing
sort of the mental resilience that's necessary or the ability to intake new bug bounty techniques,
things that have worked or that haven't worked?
And it's okay to say no, we can move on to the next question.
But, you know, it's very much a process along the way.
And it might not be a process that you're undergoing cognizantly,
something that's in the forefront of your mind.
It could rather be something that's in the back of your mind and something that you haven't really thought through.
But the whole point of this is to try to bring those things to the front of our minds
so that we can share with others how they might have a shortcut.
So do you have any thoughts on that?
It's really just me being kind of weird, probably.
But I try to...
Because when you do some hacking, you could just be basically sitting at a desk for many hours.
Just like that.
Yeah.
So I try to, you know...
One of the things that I've been trying to do these days is just, you know, sit in front of my computer for about 50 minutes.
And then, you know, have like a five minute break to do some push-ups.
Ah.
Or, you know, squats.
Right.
And then...
I've seen you do that with your little timer.
You'll set a timer and then, you know...
Sometimes.
I guess sometimes it's a stopwatch going up.
And then...
And do you ever do a one going down or is it mostly one going down?
What do you mean?
Stopwatch is...
I mean, like you press start and then it starts counting one, two, three, four, five.
And then versus a timer where a timer is...
I do both.
Oh, do you really?
Yeah.
So I...
Tell me about why do you use both?
That's a really good question.
Sometimes I...
So one of the things I really struggle with...
Is it because you're an absolute maniac and just switch it up every time?
Nah.
Okay.
You have a reason.
Sometimes I kind of want to keep track of what I've been doing.
And, you know, to sort of help myself do that successfully, I kind of...
Sometimes I just want to know how much time exactly I spent on doing one specific thing.
So, yeah, when I try to do that, it's definitely the timer, you know, going up.
Okay.
Sure.
But as I said, I do both.
I'm still doing it in a really frantic manner.
So...
Yeah.
Take it all.
Is that...
Oh, okay.
So a little sporadic, a little bit.
Yeah.
Okay.
Gotcha.
That makes sense.
I mean, but you found that that technique helps you.
And then once you get up and you do the pushups and you return to your work, that is something
that is something that sort of, for me, I think would cause some mental friction and some context switch.
So your brain says, oh, I'm working on something else.
I'm sorry, I should bring the mic with me.
Oh, I'm working on something else.
And then going back to the thing you're working on before, it's a little bit of a reset, right?
And so I try to avoid those things, but I know I acknowledge that they're necessary.
How do you...
Do you think that helps increase your focus or do you think that helps you, your focus in the short term?
Or do you think that's more of a long term, like it allows you to work more hours because you have those breaks or both?
Hmm.
Honestly, I've never really thought of it from that perspective.
I just thought, hey, I got to do something healthy for my body.
But yeah, definitely.
I think I got to pay more attention to that aspect as well.
So for you, this is more of a counteracting the physical sitting in a chair staring at a screen for a little while.
Yeah, pretty much.
That's very important.
Very good.
So that's some of the, I guess, things that have worked or things that some tips.
What kind of things do you have to share that about my mentorship style in particular or about your Bug Bounty journey that haven't worked?
And I'll toss one up there for you.
What kind of music do you guys like to listen to while you're...
Do you listen to music?
Do you listen to sounds?
Are there any experiences that you've had that...
But not loop.
Yeah.
Tell the people about that one.
So, yeah.
So I think about this topic, I think I want to talk about two things.
Okay.
Like, you know, something that haven't worked.
And the first one is kind of joke, which is about music.
Is, you know, you, cause you keep listening exact the same music for like literally for like 12 hours.
And then like keep singing the same phrase for like six hours.
And then on top of that, you say like this works, so you got to do it.
And it doesn't, right?
It doesn't.
It just doesn't work.
Yeah.
That is a little bit...
That is...
I realize now that that may not be a universal principle.
No.
So that...
Yeah.
The thing, you know, that I do...
The reason why I do that, I've explained it to you and I'll explain it to the people as
well, just in case it resounds with anyone is, I tend to get phrases or songs stuck in my head.
I'm very susceptible to earworms, right?
So when I have a song in my head, it will be taking up mental space.
And so instead of having it in my head, I opt to have it in my ears on repeat, on loop.
And what that does is it takes it out of my head, out of the working space in my head,
and puts it in the ears and makes it so I don't have to think about it.
And then that frees up that mental space, right?
For me to actually do things.
But the result of that is that I'm listening to the same song on repeat for 12 hours sometimes.
And sometimes singing the same thing on repeat for 12 hours, which can drive your mentees absolutely batty, absolutely nuts.
So, I mean, an alternative to that for you is what? What works for you?
Or did you have something else to share on the things that don't work or things that do work?
Well, yeah. So the second thing that I was going to say.
Yeah. You mentioned the second thing.
If this, because this, I think podcast is for like mentorship and stuff.
Yeah.
I think this is a case for like every mentorship with a absolute beginner and top guy.
Okay.
So, like top hackers like you have already forgot what it was like when you were a beginner.
Right.
So you forgot like what was like common sense.
And what is like something you have to learn.
Right.
So you explain something without realizing that you're like, you know, assumption is not shared by mentees.
Right. Right.
So that, but it's not just about you.
It kind of happens with.
No, no, no.
Yeah.
So say it like it's about me though.
Yeah. So.
Yeah.
Like the reason why I'm not pointing this to you is because it was like the last session was like, you know, a year ago.
So I don't like really vividly remember what kind of things that was.
I remember you giving me this feedback during our training sessions too.
And I think that's one of the things that I, I'm glad you mentioned this because that's one of the things that I wanted to sort of bring up in this.
And I saw you nodding as well.
Could I?
And this is kind of one of the things that I wanted to extract from you too during this podcast is, is, is my phone is freaking out as much as you can remember.
What is, what are the things that are common sense and are not common sense?
Right.
And, and I know that, that probably to this, you know, right now, not many things are coming to mind.
Um, but it, and as much as you can, I guess, try to equip, and it doesn't even necessarily have to be specific topics, but I guess even just equipping the listener with the ability to say, Hey, there's something that I'm missing here.
Like, like what you just said, right?
There's some assumption that you are making that I am not making and it's not clicking.
Right.
I think that's, I think that's really good as well.
So how do you, how do you identify those scenarios?
Like, to be honest, I think, uh, understanding on anything is not like black and white.
Right.
You start from zero and trying to shoot for a hundred.
So that, I think that's why it's really hard to identify is because, so the first time you hear that, like your understanding of something is like two.
Right.
But the next time you hear that, your understanding is like 45.
So that's why you understand that better.
Right.
But you don't necessarily identify why it was, there was a difference.
Sure.
And you never understand something for like a hundred percent.
Hmm.
Yeah.
You know?
No, that, that makes sense.
Could I, do you have any, any thoughts on, on any of that identifying areas that may be common sense to Justin that are preventing you from clicking?
Or is it in those scenarios, do you often just find yourself like, man, for whatever reason, this isn't clicking, maybe it's the common sense thing, you know?
Hmm.
Yeah.
One of the things I really struggled with, I mean, I still do, um, in that sense is, I think, especially for beginners, a lot of the, you know, behaviors of web browsers and, you know,
in general, maybe could be very counterintuitive and because you're already, you know, as a mentor and a, you know, an adept hacker guy, you just know, uh, you have all the, you know, knowledge and, uh, yeah.
So it's like.
So browser internals, maybe like understanding exit, like what kind of, uh, limitations there are in the browser and, and maybe even what kind of capabilities there are in the browser.
Yeah.
I remember one thing.
Okay.
Alright.
Kodai, I'm sorry.
Save.
Yeah.
Sorry, sorry.
You need to go to the file, file, save, save state, you know?
Okay.
So there was one moment.
I realized that it's not just server side and client side, you know, there is browser.
Yeah.
Client side.
And server side.
Right.
There's just ton of thing.
You cannot understand, especially with like, you know, cross site thing, cross origin thing.
Explain that a little bit.
What do you, what do you mean by that?
So like the client isn't necessarily a browser.
Is that what you're talking about or, or what?
Yeah.
So I don't, I cannot understand why I couldn't understand.
Right.
Because now I kind of understand it.
But there's server.
Right.
There's client side.
And browser visits this client side.
Mm.
Right.
So there are three parties.
Okay.
So the representation of, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wow.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
Because I do, you know, and the client side is, I guess the browser for me in some capacity,
but really the way you've described it, the browser is the piece of software that is quote unquote, processing the client side.
Yeah.
Right.
Is that, is that how you're seeing it?
I mean, not necessarily, but there's just a moment that I was like, oh, that's why there's this restriction that has to be in place to protect, you know, users.
Okay.
Because, because it's, I'm, I'm seeing, I'm seeing that.
Yeah.
That's a, that's a very interesting way of seeing it.
But you see, right.
It's kind of hard to like explain which part is important to understand, like what technology is like, it's really hard to explain, but just that whole concept.
And yeah, the browser being a piece of software itself that has, you know, saved state, right.
Mm.
With cookies and, and then, you know, a segmentation with different browser tabs and different origins and stuff like that.
Yeah.
And all of that is represented in just the, you know, client side response from, from the server, right.
The, cause you could hit it with curl and you'd get some data back.
Right.
But the browser is a much more complex mechanic.
Yeah.
Is that sort of what you're talking about?
But at the same time, yeah, I agree with that.
Then same time, sometimes browser visits client side.
Mm.
Like when you use the Chrome instead of curl.
Then, it then looks like they're just two parties, you know, kind of things.
Mm.
And then it renders and that's right.
Yeah.
And then you just get confused.
Right.
Yeah.
That's an interesting, that's an interesting way of understanding it.
I, I, I think, you know, if I try to force my own understanding on you of that, you know, it could become confusing.
And also like, even, even me right now, I couldn't, I mean, I cannot understand why I couldn't understand that three years ago.
Mm.
So, right.
If, if, you know, three years ago, me came up here, I, I think I would do the same thing as, as Justin.
Right.
Like three years ago, like, you know, having hard time explaining like common sense.
Sure.
Yeah.
So that's how, yeah.
That makes sense.
So, so bringing it back to Kodai, sorry.
Thank you for interjecting there.
So, um, so you were saying, you know, I guess just making the mentee in the situation aware of sort of how the
browser works and what kind of restrictions are in the browser.
That's where a lot of the assumptions are coming in.
Is that, is that kind of what you were saying?
Yeah, kind of.
And it's just, it's not necessarily, it's not just about, you know, web browsers.
It could be just, you know, just.
Yeah.
Anything like multiple servers and stuff.
And yeah, it's so, it has been really easy for me to lose track of what was going on.
Like, you know, in the middle of listening to you.
Um, your explanation basically.
Right.
Oh, like.
Even when we use.
What happened when.
Right.
And do you think it helped in particular when we used visual representations like on a whiteboard?
Yeah.
That was, that was big for you.
That was a massive help.
Okay.
Gotcha.
Good.
Look at that guys.
Some good, some good feedback.
Don't listen to, uh, to songs on loop for 12 hours, at least not over, you know, speakers
rather than in headphones.
Mm-hmm.
And, uh, try to be aware of the common sense bias.
Right.
Also like, I think I have another solution for me that I found is, so these days I work a lot with Reota.
Yeah.
You know, obviously another super good hackers.
Mm-hmm.
So he does a lot of things to me like where, you know, there are like a lot of, you know, common sense gaps.
Yeah.
So, I do all the time and what he says to me all the time is like, okay, let's just stop this and, you know, just, you know, put this aside for a few months.
And then I come back to the same, same concept, like three months later to see if I understand that, you know,
And like, and that, that, that works.
Yeah.
That works.
We kind of, we kind of give up understanding that he kind of give up teaching me that.
Yeah.
And I kind of give up understanding that to my third, I'm like, Oh, why I didn't understand that, you know, that's another solution.
That is, that's so foreign to me.
Yeah.
I would never, ever, ever, ever, ever do that.
You know, like that.
And this is great because that's a brilliant segue into the next section that I wanted to say, which was like, how has it, has your, you know, and also I'll let you, I'll cue this up and let you guys think about it for a second.
How has working with other hackers influenced your hacking?
So, you know, for you, maybe that's so, or, or any other hackers you've collaborated with, you know, being near the life hacking events, or maybe it's just me, you know, I don't know how much collaboration you've done outside, but so you've done, you know, some other collaborations.
How has that been and what things have been different that you've learned?
Now, that crazy ass thing you said a second ago about Uriota, dude, I can't, I can't even process that.
Because like, for me, if I let something like that go, all the, all of the working memory, you know, all of the data in RAM, just, just drops, right?
And, and sure, maybe I'm a little bit more of a mature hacker, you know, a couple months down the line.
But man, maybe it's just the stubbornness too, that I just don't want to let that thing even temporarily defeat me.
I don't even want to lose the battle, even if it's going to win me the war in the long run.
And actually, this, this correlates me, this may just be my personality too, because I know you guys know Mariah and how Mariah and I work.
But let's say Mariah and I are having an argument, right?
In the moment, I'll be like, we got to fix this right now, you know, and we just got to talk this through.
And then we'll just be back to normal and everything will be better, right?
But for Mariah, sometimes it, it, it say, hey, we need to take even a five or 10 minute break and just breathe and then just come back to the situation, right?
I see that.
I can picture that.
Yeah, yeah.
Whereas I, I would never do anything like that.
So, it's good to see.
I mean, so that's great to hear that you found other, you know, other mentors or other, you know, hackers to collaborate with that have also shared with you other ways of, of, you know, growing and finding essentially a scenario where it's like, okay, well, hey, you don't understand that now.
And that's okay.
But let's come back to this a little bit and maybe putting a reminder on your calendar on your to do list or something, say, revisit this topic.
Yeah.
So, okay.
Hopefully, you haven't been too engaged in what I'm saying.
And you've been thinking about what, what other hackers you've, you've worked with a little bit.
Could I, do you, I mean, why don't you start?
Because I'm not, I'm not sure you, do you have other hackers that you've collaborated with?
Obviously, so, but besides me?
Um, not really.
I mean, Soma.
Yeah, that's true.
Yeah.
And other friend of ours.
He was actually on probably the episode 10 of this podcast.
Yeah.
But, yeah, I, I think only him really outside of, you know, not outside.
He's still inside of this inner circle.
Right, right, right, right, right.
Yeah.
So we, we, we throw him, he's in software.
It's a little different, you know?
So, yeah.
I mean, I think that's a little bit different, you know?
Something's a little bit wrong with him.
Um, uh, yeah.
So, okay, you've worked a little bit with, with, with Soma.
Um, but besides that, mostly just me and So.
Yeah.
Yeah, all right.
Well, that'll be an interesting journey for you to see, you know, as you start collaborating
with other hackers.
So you've worked pretty heavily with, with, dozo tote.
Um, you've worked pretty heavily with Ryota and, and some other hackers as well.
Um, Ryota and I are very different.
Uh, anything, any, um, any sort of, I guess, I almost want to say culture shock, but anything,
you know, what, what are some things that have worked better with you, with Ryota, or that
have worked differently with, with Ryota?
Obviously you've got the, the Japanese piece, right?
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
So is that in terms of mentorship or is this in terms of like generally?
In terms of general hacking or mentorship.
And then also, yeah, maybe, maybe actually take a second to talk about the bilingual piece
of this as well, because, you know, we tried to do, it was actually a part of the way that
I picked up Japanese, was trying to teach you hacking in Japanese and you correcting my
Japanese and that sort of thing.
But that's a very slow and painful process to try to hear a non-native speaker explain stuff.
And also there's a lot of English terms, right?
So, um, how has it worked with you being, having a conversation with Ryota in your native language?
Uh, and how has that helped you understand things or get a better grip on, on stuff?
Um, so, uh, for one, I guess, uh, you know, having, um, training with you in English and Japanese,
I didn't really feel like language barrier.
Mm.
And like, this is actually maybe just about me, but like, for example, if I read some document in English
and then later visit the same thing, translator in Japanese, especially with, uh, like technology thing,
it's easier to understand in English because everything's from the, not always from the States,
but everyone writes their rights up in English.
Ah, so the original is in English.
Yeah.
And that, because of that, you get the nuance better.
So there's some friction in terms of language, but if I read, um, translated version,
I have a friction of translation in my mind.
So it's not necessarily a huge barrier.
Yeah.
That makes sense.
And when you've worked with, uh, Ryota, obviously you're speaking Japanese with him.
Um, do you think you've been able to understand concepts any better when Ryota explains them in Japanese?
Or, um, I guess he explains like super hard things.
So.
Yeah.
But like, I really appreciate that he speaks Japanese.
Mm.
Yeah.
Of course.
Uh, one, because we can, I can understand.
I mean, like I can get any nuances better in Japanese.
Mm.
Um, I don't know.
I don't know.
It's just in terms of technology and techniques and stuff.
I think it's not necessarily the case.
Maybe like if someone can speak Japanese, it's easier to, you know, get along with that.
Because it's hard.
It's hard facts.
Most of the time.
It's not like nuance a lot of times.
Yeah.
Right.
I guess that, that sort of makes sense as well.
And, and you guys are to the point, you know, where you're fluent enough in English, obviously,
because we're doing this podcast in English, where, you know, most of the hard facts, most
of the, you know, pretty straightforward, you know, things that don't have a lot of wiggle
room, uh, those, those come, come through pretty well, I'd imagine.
Um, any other, any other thoughts?
So on collaboration with other hackers, as you move sort of out of this mentee stage into full-fledged
collaboration, I guess like we, realtor, it's not really like a collaboration.
It's kind of same as you, but like the big difference is, I think you're, you can do both
black box and white box, but I think you have more experience on black box.
I think real does the opposite.
He can do both, but he's strong is a white box.
So I, whenever I learned from that.
Like from realtor, I learned something different from like what I learned from you.
So, yeah, I think that's another big difference, I guess.
So how did you establish that relationship with Uriyota where you were getting that information
back and forth in the beginning?
Was it you messaging him a lot or did he sort of pursue you with that?
I mean, it's always me messaging, like spamming realtor on Discord.
All right.
So I think there's a lesson there, right?
Well, what's that lesson?
If you find someone really good at hacking, just spam them.
Just a joke.
Nice.
Okay.
Solid.
Well, seriously, there are many people like, you know, really generous in this industry.
I'm sure I'm serious about that.
Like you, realtor.
I mean, realtor get like zero yen or zero dollar if you prefer.
Yeah.
But he still answers a lot of questions.
So, yeah.
Yeah.
That's really, that is cool.
And I guess, you know, like you said, spamming, I think spamming is not exactly what you're
doing, right?
You're, you're, you normally in my experience with you, despite there being a lot of messages,
those messages are pointed and they are specific and they are good questions essentially, right?
Not, not stuff that you would be able to look up on Google or things that you could ask, you know,
chat GPT or whatever.
Right.
And, and because of that, I think, I think that makes it a lot easier for us to answer, you know,
those things.
So I think that's good.
All right.
Let me see, let me see where we're at here.
We're doing another mobile recording.
So it's a little bit outside of the normal flow of things.
All right.
We're at an hour 10.
Let's see if there's anything else that we want to talk about here.
Yeah.
So, yeah.
So this last little sort of section is kind of reigniting the, the mentorship of sorts.
Okay.
And kind of talking about where you guys, let's talk honestly about where you guys are at in
your hacker journey and what kind of things you would like to change or grow in.
Okay.
So since you've got a little bit more experience, I'm going to let you think on that one a little
bit.
Um, would you give me a little bit of a summary on what kind of things you're, you're working
on or what kind of, uh, weaknesses that you'd like to try to overcome right now?
Sure.
Um, so what I'm currently working on is I basically, I'm in the process of trying to have a more comprehensive
understanding of, uh, common vulnerability types because I only know, uh, just several
vulnerabilities.
Eye door and access control pretty much.
Right?
Yeah.
So I'm working on that and because of, you know, lack of knowledge, I sometimes try to do some
bug bounty, but cannot really go super deep, like into one program.
So in a way, maybe it's, I feel like it's making it easier for me to sort of almost move on because,
Hey, there's not much I can do.
That I understand.
Yeah.
So, you know, whenever that happens, I try to, you know, kind of be road back to port
swigger or something and, or, you know, just reading some reports and like how, Hey, this
one, you know, other vulnerability works.
Like recently I studied SSRF and stuff.
Yeah.
So starting to get a grip on those slowly, slowly, but surely.
And so when you, when you get into a program and you start hacking and then you're, you
know, you're not finding vulnerabilities, could you describe the feelings that are coming
up and that, uh, like the, is there frustration there?
Is there, do you feel confident in your direction that you're going, you know, how, how is that?
I know, I know.
I will say I'm asking you guys to be pretty vulnerable here because there are a lot of people
that from our side, uh, as the hacker says, genuinely want to help, you know, people to
grow.
Right.
And there are a lot of people in your shoes that genuinely want to grow and they want to
overcome these sort of feelings that they're having.
And I think knowing that there are other people experiencing those things and overcoming them
as you guys are, I think that helps.
So I'm sorry for putting you on the spot with some difficult questions about yourself and your
current journey, but I think it's, it'll be helpful.
Yeah.
Um, sorry.
Uh, I haven't really, in a pragmatic sense implemented this method yet, but, um, yeah,
the feeling of, Hey, maybe there's not much I can do that.
I understand that definitely makes me, um, you know, frustrated and lost to a degree, but,
um, sorry, what was the question again?
Yeah.
I guess, so that, that, that makes sense, you know, lost to a degree.
Right.
And, and, and so I guess what, what are, what are some other things that are sort of coming
up as you're, as you're going through that and how does that affect your journey?
Like, do you leave the computer frustrated or, and how do you sort of process that?
Uh, what kind of stuff's coming up?
Yeah.
Um, but I, I'm aware that there's a need for me to, you know, in that sort of situation,
at least lay out, you know, all the things that I've already tried.
Mm.
Good.
And, and then move on or still, you know, stick to what I was working on.
Mm.
Yeah.
How much time are you spending on a target before you move along, go back to education?
Not a great question.
Um, just a ballpark's fine.
You know, I realize you're probably not recording this, you know, did four hours on this target
today or whatever.
No, probably should.
Yeah.
I think that'd be helpful.
I don't know.
It could be sometimes super, I guess, unnecessarily long sometimes.
Mm.
Yeah.
Just for almost a week.
So like, although I-
Yeah.
Roughly 40 hours or roughly 30 hours in a week?
Like roughly, yeah.
30 to 35 hours a week.
Okay.
Like, although I don't really have, you know, I don't even understand many types of vulnerabilities.
Right.
And we've kind of talked about this as well as like, you know, you're going in there,
you're spending time in the requests, reading the requests, right?
Mm.
Trying to understand what's happening.
And, you know, maybe you'll leave that situation frustrated that maybe you haven't found a volume.
But every single time you read a request and you try to understand what's going on,
you're gaining reps.
You know, you're, you're, it's like, you know, it's like you're doing the workout,
you know, and you're, you're becoming stronger at analyzing requests, understanding what's
happening and reducing that friction to the next time you try and attack vector.
Um, so yeah, I think, I think 40 hours, um, on a target.
Uh, you know, I think like you said that that's probably, or, or 30, 30 to 35 is what he said.
Um, probably, probably a tad bit long without, without, you know, having more direction or more.
It's probably about right, you know, about, but maybe on the long side, if you've only got two, two vulnerability types.
Right. I mean, would you, you're making some, uh, sort of agreement sounds.
So do you, do you agree with that or do you disagree with that?
Like, do you think that's long for him to be on a target at this point in his, in his journey?
I mean, I actually was thinking from pretty different perspective, which is that.
So I think like the biggest difference, uh, between you and us is like, we really lack a lot of basics.
So sometimes I feel like the reason why I don't find that they, the same amount of access control bugs,
like even in IDORS as you, it's not because I don't have enough reps, but also because you have generally better understandings on like different things.
And I don't know how they're all connected, but cause that kind of same argument as, you know, better hacker knows like how to call stuff.
So, and so I guess that basic knowledge, are you saying that that's something more like, so I'm able to extract more attack surface out of the, the, the program or out of the application?
Or do you think that's actually like, you know, basic knowledge as in like, for example, um, because at the end of the day, IDORS are IDORS.
You sub the IDs, you know, you figure it out.
We all know how that works.
Right.
You know, the reason you're not finding the IDORS is there's two reasons.
One, you didn't try the request.
Two, you didn't find the request.
But for example, if you take a Jason, for example,
Yeah.
Um, the first few months, I didn't know that swapping, you know, key value stuff really make most of the time no difference.
Sometimes, of course.
Right.
But if you have like completely different keys, and then swapping them doesn't really affect anything.
Sure.
I didn't know that.
So I think I would, I had tried, you know, swapping them at least once, but it's a waste of time.
Swapping, swapping meaning what?
Like changing the order of the keys?
Yeah.
But that's very limited scenarios where that, that, you know, has some input.
But it's like a test, you know, backslash end, maybe that works.
Right.
But test one, test two, I don't know.
Kind of.
So then I waste time there.
The same like for cash behavior.
Sure.
Sometimes you say like, this is dead end.
Right.
But I just, you know, keep pushing forward for like another hour to realize that this is, this is actually dead end.
Sure.
But then I kind of start to think like, maybe I have to increase like general understanding of cybersecurity, computer science.
So yeah, I think that that's what I was thinking.
I like how so many of your examples are about JSON pollution right now, because you read that article recently.
You're like, oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Also because you, you brought up JSON as the first thing I learned.
Right.
Ever since that day, he's been obsessed with JSON.
Yeah, that, that makes sense.
Having some things that you don't, that you, you've got to kind of figure out for yourself are dead ends, you know, and also testing the assumptions.
We talk about this a lot on the podcast, but everyone has their own set of eyes.
Right.
And I can tell you so that that's a dead end.
But until you've gone down that path, it's hard for you to know that that's a dead end.
And that's the hacker mentality, right?
Because every time you, you try to, you know, go to slash admin, you're going to get 403.
Right.
But you can't trust that 403, you know, and you got to try admin slash, you got to try admin percent OA slash, you know,
you know, that too, if you know what it's like, you know, what backend is like, if you have ever seen like engine X configuration once,
Right.
You might think about that.
Yeah.
Right.
But if you have never seen that, it's just a waste of time.
Yeah.
Because you don't know how things could get wrong, go wrong.
So I guess the thing that I was, I was, so I guess bringing that back around to Kodai's situation, you know, spending 30 hours or 35 hours, you know, with two, two vulnerability types.
I think there's sort of a blog post that I'm working on with essentially a percentages scenario, you know, layout where I say, okay, you know, after you know, I do access control bugs, SSS, XSS, C surf.
And then, you know, maybe a couple other things.
You should be spending 60% of your time hacking and 40% of your time learning.
Right.
Because those bugs make up the majority of, you know, the bugs that are found.
But, you know, Kodai is not quite at that spot yet.
So I think Kodai, you might still be at like an 80-20.
Right.
Where in a week you're spending, you know, 80% of your time learning and then 20% of your time actually hacking.
And as that continues to grow, you know, as you, you know, your, your vulnerabilities that you're comfortable with continue to grow, that's when you sort of increase the, the attacking, the actual hacking piece, the hands on the keyboard piece.
Does that make sense?
Does that resound with you?
Yeah, it does.
You should grab the mic for that.
We really got one mic.
Sorry about that.
Does that resound with you?
It does.
Yeah.
I think that might help reduce frustration and help increase, you know, feeling of progress in bug bounty.
What kind of vulnerabilities right now?
You mentioned SSRF.
Is that been your primary focus for the past couple weeks or are there other vulnerabilities that you're learning about?
XXE injections.
Oh, nice.
Yeah.
And I also try to look for some CSRFs as well.
Ah, nice.
Yeah.
And a bit of exorcist.
Very nice.
Yeah.
Um, good stuff, dude.
I guess that's about it.
Nice.
Keep at it.
Uh, for those of you listening, I just gave Kodai a little, little fist bump and it kind
of, kind of hurt the knuckles.
All right.
So, so, so talk to me a little bit about where you're at in your journey, what kind of
things you're trying to improve on and what kind of stuff you're trying to, um, uh,
yeah, grow in what's working, what's not working for you right now.
Yeah.
So, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so,
so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so,
so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so
sometimes, do bug bounty and then try to apply all these things that I learned in, like, in the last two weeks or three.
Yeah.
Into practice.
That's, like, yeah, what I do.
That's pretty solid.
Let's, let's, let's, let's call some shots here.
Where do you want to be in, in two years?
Where do you want to be in two years careerally?
And where do you want to be, you know, I guess, from a technical perspective, what things do you want to understand?
What kind of bugs do you want to be finding?
You know, what kind of research do you want to be doing?
Similar things or?
Yeah, I'm thinking.
Yeah.
Show the shirt.
He's wearing a shirt right now that says thinking and then has a loading bar that's halfway, halfway done.
That's great.
It's really hard.
So, one, there are a lot of things that I learned.
There are a lot of blog posts published, like, every day.
So, like, on a daily basis, I don't really have, like, specific direction to go.
I just have a lot of things that I learned, that I love to learn.
So, I just do it.
And just really vaguely, I think it'd be really cool if I can do something like what people in Asset Notes do.
Like, their blog posts are, like, just crazy, right?
Yeah, we all, we all.
Right?
We would all love to do that.
Yeah, yeah.
So, like, at some point, it would be really cool if I can do kind of same thing, which is, you know, finding, like, crazy exploit on, like, big vendor.
So, sort of semi-white box security research.
Yeah.
Right?
But, yeah, black box is cool, too.
So, yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, and what Asset Notes does is not necessarily white box, but they try it as best they can to make it white box, right?
They try as much as they can to get their hands on source code and do reverse engineering.
And sometimes they have to deal with the binary exploitation stuff, and sometimes they get their hands on source code.
Yeah, so that's white box.
So, I think in terms of black box, like, something like, I can't just pronounce his name, but Yosef Samura?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
If I can just, oh, like, in the front row.
His stuff is largely white box, too, because it's front end, and you have front end code.
Yeah, so I think that's maybe, like, something, at least a bit of source code-y thing is what I want to do, I guess.
That's cool.
Yeah.
So, you kind of want to go down the source code reading and then vulnerability finding ground.
Nice.
Kodai, I think your goals are a little different.
You know, you mentioned before being able to live a nomadic life, right?
You want to be able to travel around and work on your schedule.
What kind of goals do you have for the future in Bug Bounty?
So, as I said at the beginning of this podcast, I'm in the process of, you know, applying for some actual companies right now.
Yeah.
So, I just can't say, hey, I'm only, you know, just focusing on doing some Bug Bounty.
Right, right, of course, of course.
And as much as I would, I tell you all the time, man, Bug Bounty's the life.
You know, I totally understand that.
And, you know, some jobs allow to work remote and some jobs don't allow to work remote.
And I think it's important for you to get in there and, you know, have some career experiences as well.
Yeah, yeah.
So, it doesn't have to be limited.
Let's just make this more broadly.
Let's make it career-ily.
Yeah, so, it's like, you know, that being said, I do still want to have the capability of, you know, working and living nomadically, like, regardless of my decisions.
So, yeah.
So, let me make this question a little bit more specific.
In two to five years, where would you like to see yourself?
If one of the companies that I'm applying for right now, really, if one of them really, like, clicked, then I might just, you know, naturally stick to it.
Yeah.
To it, but if that wasn't the case, I think I'd have tried to spend more time in Bug Bounty.
And, of course, if that didn't really work temporarily, then I try to, you know, do more and more studying, learning, just like, you know, so does.
And, yeah.
Yeah, that makes sense.
Do you see Bug Bounty more as a stepping stone for you?
Like, as a stair to get to a destination, you know?
Or do you see Bug Bounty as something that might stay in your life more long-term after you get a job?
I don't want it to stay in my life.
Because all the Bug Bounty hunters that I've seen, they're so, they're all super cool, including you guys.
Yeah.
And, yeah, you just, you know, I just wanted something really badass in my life.
So, did you say you do or you don't want it to stay in your life?
I would.
You do.
Okay.
Sorry, Kodai.
I misheard you there.
Sorry about that.
But...
Sorry, my poor articulation.
No, no, you're good.
We always try to, we always troll Kodai because he spends so much time, you know, really articulating and speaking really well in English.
So, anytime I miss anything, I have to give him a...
Ah!
Gotcha.
So, what about you?
We'll close with this one.
But, like, do you think you see yourself staying in Bug Bounty or do you think Bug Bounty is a training thing for you?
I mean, I think I love to stay in Bug Bounty.
And that's just simply because the very first reason I ditched, like, being diplomat course...
Right, right.
Is because I thought it's super cool to, you know, be like you, be like, you know, top hacker, you know, finding crazy vulnerabilities and protecting the world.
That sounds really cool.
So, I think that's the first inspiration.
So, I think that's going to stick to my mind.
I mean, for long term, I guess.
Good, good shit, guys.
All right, let's do it.
Let's rock it.
Let's find those, let's find those vulns.
So, as we finish off this episode, Kodai's got a little bit of a word of advice for an admonition for those of you listening on YouTube.
What is that, Kodai?
What have you always wanted to say to the viewers?
Yeah, just, you know, thank you all for watching this, listening to this podcast.
And just definitely smash the description and leave some likes in the comment section.
Smash the description.
That's crucial.
It's crucial.
That's crucial right there.